to our next speaker up present on
computing probablistic by similar
distances the apology iteration so it's
a joint work with my graduate student
g10 so the the talk will be in two parts
first I'll talk about models and in the
second part I will talk about algorithms
it isn't related to to the previous talk
and you'll see a number of notions
popping up that that we've seen before
your overall talk is is related to this
fundamental question so when do two
states of a particular model behave the
same and for this we usually use
behavioral equivalences I mean many have
been introduced over the last thirty
years and so we're looking at these
equivalence relations in particular for
a model that we're interested in which
are labeled markov chains so these are
normal Markov chains we have a a bunch
of states you have probabilities going
from one state to another and and we
label the states and the labeling is
done by in this example by by coloring
the states and it captures properties
that hold in those particular states so
for example these three states have the
same properties and these two have have
different properties from those other
ones so the transitions which will play
a key role I will model by by a function
so it's a function from the set of
states
I assume this said to be may be finite
to distributions on on this set so if we
look for example at this one over here
toe of s will be a distribution of s and
it it maps to the state you have to the
state via half and to all other state
zero so we use this later on so now the
notion of equivalence for these type of
systems was introduced by Larson and
score known as probablistic by
simulation so a relation on the states
is called a probability by simulation
first of all if related states satisfy
the same properties so that means that
their labels are the same and
furthermore there's some dynamics so
your in these two states and now you
make a transition but remember the
transition function takes a state to a
distribution on States so so what we get
is we have this despair now of
distributions that we want to see that
they are related in some way as well so
what we have to do is we have to take a
relation on states of the system to a
relation on distribution over those
states so we have to lift this this
notion of relation which I'll do in in
in a minute
so once we have this notion then
probablistic by similarity will be the
largest such such equivalence relation
so how can you do the lifting so this is
one way so you take an equivalence
relation and now you lift it to a
relation on distributions and so two
measures or two probability
distributions are related if they assign
the same probability mass to two
equivalence classes so the idea modest
is that so what when are two states the
same decides the side is the same
properties and also if you you make a
transition then you go with the same
probability to equivalence classes or
States again next what I will do is I'll
provide an alternative characterization
of this if this notion of lifting which
I will use later on as well so key
ingredient of this alternative
characterization is the notion of
coupling so given two probability
distributions then you then a coupling
is again a probability distribution but
this time on the on the product space
such that mu and you are the marginals
and that is captured by by these two
equations and this will be the notation
that I will be using for the set of all
the couplings so might be helpful to
actually look at an example to see how
this notion of coupling works so so what
we could have is it is a following
situation again you can think of these
as states and transitions but you can
also think of this as a as a probability
distribution so the probability of being
here is a half and probability of being
here is a half as well and the similar
on this side so we have now mu and nu
another way to actually view this is to
think of this as a transportation
problem so we have a bunch of stuff
let's say one unit of stuff which is
over here half is transported over here
have is transported over here and now I
want to do is want to transport it from
this ability distribution to this one
over here and so how much do we want
over here 1/2 and how much you want over
here 1/2 and now the way to transport
this these are actually the couplings
again the coupling what does it do it it
maps every pair of probability that's
the amount of mass that we're going to
support from one state to another so for
example one way to do this is to
transport it in this way right so we're
just transporting a half over here and a
hat over here
but of course you could also cross for
example there would be another example
of a coupling or the transportation so
the alternative characterization now in
terms of these couplings of this notion
of lifting is the following so again we
have two distributions and they're in
the lifting if and only if we can find a
coupling such that the support of this
coupling is a subset of the of the
equivalence relation so now they're
there they're infinitely many couplings
are infinitely many ways in order
transport information from the one side
or other stuff from one side to the
other for example you know we can pick
any R in this in this interval over here
and then transport this and then
transport that so once you choose the
yard and of course you get to the other
transportation part as well
I only have a half here to transport
right so the maximum I can transport
from here will be a half right so so
they're infinitely many however I mean
this is this set of of couplings is a
convex polytope and a property that
we'll use in a bit is that a concave
function on such a polytope attains its
minimum at a vertex and the the set of
vertices which I will use with this this
V over here today note is actually a
finite set so and in this particular
case are only only to two vertices so
only when you choose R to be 0 or 1/2 so
these are always the extremal ones that
you can have and what one can show is
that again for the lifting you only have
to show that there exists a vertex that
has this property as before so you can
actually restrict to the vertices rather
than looking at the complete polytope
just to give you an idea of roughly how
to to prove this so what you could do is
you could take all the states to set s
and you order them in such a way that
related States related according to the
equivalence relation r are next to each
other so once you've done that you can
run the northwest corner method which is
for example you use for in your
programming and this is a now you get a
really simple algorithm with a bunch of
loops and some some nested loops as well
and now actually proving this result
really boils down to proving a bunch of
of loop invariants so initially I try to
do this by hand and failed miserably
because I would make all kind of silly
small mistakes so I recently been using
this tool Daphney which allows you
actually to to annotate this is this
simple program with loop invariants and
it actually proves it all automatically
in your previous example what is our bar
is a set of all four possible
transitions or what is part one that's
still so that the our bar so ours is a
relation on the on the states and now
you want to lift it to a relation on the
on the measure I think I'll have an
example later on efficient and if I
don't answer your question feel free to
interrupt me again then I'll try it
again
alright so so we have this notion of
behavioral equivalence for these systems
but it's well known that this notion is
not very robust and was it mean is that
if if two states that are considered to
be equivalent if you if you change the
probabilities just slightly
they might become in equivalent or vice
versa and since we generally get these
numbers just by running some experiments
or possibly even by guessing I mean it
is it's tricky to use this very strict
boolean type of notion and therefore
others have ever suggested to use
instead of a behavioral equivalence to
use something which is called a pseudo
metric so rather than saying yes or no
they behave exactly the same what we do
is we give a kind of a quantitative
measure of how similar the behavior is
of the states and the idea is that the
smaller the distance between two states
the more likely behave and if the
distance is zero then they behave
exactly the same so going back down to
probablistic by similarity a little bit
more interesting example here again we
have a distribution here and here and
this is the condition that we have to
satisfy in order to do the lifting so
now indeed let's come up with a relation
so the the green edges capture which
states are related and now what we want
to do is we want to find a way
to transport the such that were only
using the green edges right and so we
can do this right so for example third
over here third over here these are
connected these are connected and one
thread over here and these are connected
as well so this now shows that if you
have are the relation and you have a
measure over here in a measure over here
then these two measures are in the
lifting of our because this this
condition is satisfied
so now in order to move towards from
this boolean notion to something more
quantitive what I'll do is I'll first
start with taking this relation and
already more as describing it as a
distance like function so we say that if
the states are related we map it to zero
otherwise we map it to one and we had
this this this condition that the
support of the coupling should be a
subset of R so now you can rewrite this
in the following way
right so you can say that this weighted
sum has to be 0 so now the next step
what we're going to do is we're going to
take this relation and map it into a
pseudo metric so it's not going to be 0
1 but here we're going to get arbitrary
real numbers in the unit interval and so
of course at that point we cannot really
insist on this being 0 anymore but what
we can try to do is we can try to
minimize this so in a sense what we're
trying to do is find the coupling that
minimizes this sum right this is now
going to be a real valued function
rather than a discrete function so in
this in it in this setting
remoras allowing you know to transport
anywhere we like but remember that we've
replaced the relation with the distance
function so there's a cost associated
with moving in two different between
different states and now what we try to
do is we try to minimize we try to find
an optimal coupling that minimizes this
weighted sum that's all can you
interpret can you take the metric just
like one on the support of our infinite
outside of something and when you mean
my zip you're solving the
problem so probably by similarity
exactly if and only if distances are
zero in this particular setting so in
that sense it gives you an didi can i
embed the exact trick so I pick a
particular D and I apply you're
minimizing objective and my D is somehow
I put the points that I'm the support of
our distance one or something and the
ones that are not connected that
distance infinite if I minimize that
will I find the same concept as before
yes it's like a single step notion of
similarity where is so is there is there
a notion which say pays attention to
what where things lead to further on in
time because if for example there could
be is some small transition to a
different state maybe maybe it doesn't
cause I don't quite understand it this
yet but maybe it's it maybe it doesn't
cause a distance a little too bad down
the road and then with that would that
be reflected a measure like this or not
it is somewhat reflected in it and I
will see that later on because actually
the the distance function itself is
defined as a fixed point so you will see
changes in in the future as well so here
we're looking at indeed at one step but
then when I once I introduce the
distance function itself you'll see that
this is defined recursively so it will
capture that there are also many other
distances that have been introduced for
for these type of systems that are
defined in different ways and more along
the lines that you see which is yes
so this was the definition of
probability by similarity right the
largest equivalence relation labels are
the same and we have to be able to find
a coupling that has this property so now
if we want to generalize this what we
would get is the following so we now get
the smallest distance function and
smallest because we decided that zero
match is true in some sense and so
therefore one is false so obviously if
the labels are different we want them to
be maximally different different because
it you want to model flip this this idea
over here and then the extension
quantifier becomes a minimum and as we
already discussed before this is over
here becomes this this weighted sum so
this was the the distance function that
was introduced in the in the late 90s by
death and Gupta and panic garden and and
one of the fundamental results that they
proved in their paper is that prob
listed by similarity exactly coincides
with states having distance 0
so this is indeed closely related to the
earth moving a distance it has many many
other names including the contour of
each metric so this is the definition
that we more or less recognize from from
one of the previous slides and as I said
you know concave functions take their
minimum at a vertex so really that's why
these two equations are the same this is
concave and so we can really become can
focus on the vertices and then this one
over here is is a duality theorem due to
controversy and rubenstein and this is
what you usually find as the definition
of the arrangement so in the second part
of the talk about I'll present some
algorithms in order to access
approximate and compute these these
distance functions
you know I'll quickly show three
algorithms and then I'll focus in on on
one of them and then we'll come back to
games as we seen in the previous talk
and hopefully the last part as well
otherwise we'll skip over so how can we
compute these these distances now that
we've defined them so the first approach
that we took was using the theory of the
over the reals so what you can do is you
can express this over here so the
distance between s and T is smaller than
some rational Q you can express it in
the first-order theory over the reals
and then you just use binary search
right so your first check is the
distance smaller than 1/2 if it is it's
more than 1/4 if not it's more than 3/8
and so on and so so in this way you
approximate it so at least that showed
that you can compute these distances but
not very efficiently so after that we
were trying to find out a better way to
do this and it turns out that you can
actually Express the distance between
two states as one big linear programming
problem which you can then solve using
the ellipsoid method and for those
familiar with the method you need a
separation Oracle
in this case you have to solve some sort
of minimum cost flow problem and that
you can use the network network simplex
algorithm and you can do this how big is
the linear program it's it's it's
pranaam wheel size of the of the of the
system so it does give give rise to a
polynomial time algorithm and the third
algorithm was introduced by Bucky Bucky
Larson and Madonna and they use
different techniques related to some of
the ingredients that I've presented to
you at the first part the algorithm
itself consists of of a basic algorithm
and I'll focus on that only in this
store plus some optimization and the
idea is that you try to compute
distances on the fly so you're not
computing all of them but only those
that you that you really need but I will
not focus on this although all the
results that I present actually carry
over to the full algorithm so it is all
based on a simple stochastic game so let
me quickly introduce those they're
simpler than the one that Marta
presented to us so it's a directed graph
you have a bunch of different nosy of
mid-notes Mack knows average knows they
have two sinks zero sink and no.1 sink
and our two players there's a mint
player and a max player so if you're in
a min node the min player plays and the
max node the Max anair plays if you're
an average note you know with 50% you go
over here and with 50% you go over here
so what are the objectives the max
player tries to maximize the probability
of reaching the one sink and the main
player obviously tries to either avoid
ever reaching this one or it tries to
reach the zero sink so now you can
assign to every note of the of the graph
a value which is molested the
probability that the max player will win
so for example if you're in this note
then there's
no way that the the max player can win
you always go to 2-0 right so this would
have value zero this one will have value
1/2 this will have value 1/2 and this
will have value 1/2 plus something more
right possibly because that's going over
here so now again what would be a good
strategy for the max player from over
here this is 0 this is 1/2 so the
strategy would be to go over here right
and here the strategy would be 1/2 or
something
1/2 plus something more so the strategy
would be to go over here and finally
here the main player has to choose
between 1/2 or 1/2 plus something more
so if we're probably well it'll I will
choose this strategy over here so as
already mentioned the value of a vertex
is the is the probability that the max
player will win the game provided that
both play optimal so now what we can can
do is we can take a labeled markov chain
and we can map it to a simple stochastic
game in such a way that the distance
between the states so action by the way
I should mention that you map every pair
of states in the labeled markov chain to
a vertex of the game such that every the
distance between every pair of states is
exactly the value of the vertex and for
the furthermore there's a an algorithm
called simply policy iteration which
exactly now boils down to the the
algorithm that was introduced by Bochy
at all so how do you do this so you take
a pair of states of the level Markov
chain if the labels are different well
then we know that the distance is 1 they
behave very differently so you map it to
the 1 sink if they are probabilistic by
similar then we know that the distance
is 0 they bathe exactly the same so we
map it to the 0 sink and otherwise what
do we do
so we have a pair States s and T so we
have an edge to all the vertices and now
of course here it's essential to use
vertices so that we get a finite set and
then we
this has to be a min note so we're
minimizing over all the vertices and
then these are our average notes so
that's what we get this this sum over
here since this is an average note you
you have to associate with it a
probability remember that this is a
coupling so it assigns to every pair of
states of probability and that's exactly
the probability of this this edge over
here so this maps now the labeled Markov
chain to a simple stochastic game and
then simple policy iteration allows you
to compute the values and so what do you
do you choose an initial policy also
might I mention this and mention the
word strategy which is also often used
and as long as there's a particular
vertex in it in the game that is not
locally optimal then what you do is you
switch it to the T or the an optimal one
so you adjust it locally and you keep
doing this until everything is locally
optimal and then you can there's a
condom showed that if the game
terminates with probability 1 then it
actually computes the global optimum as
well skip this part
so one of the things that we've done is
we've shown that the algorithm is
exponential and so I'll give you a and
again I mean the obvious ways to
implement an an n-bit counter in order
to show this so let me show you a simple
example so this is the the counter
example so this is a labeled markov
chain and so what we do is we take this
labelled markov chain and at first we we
build a game from it and the game looks
like this these over here are all min
notes and the dots over here are the are
the average notes and as you can see it
it doesn't include any max notes in this
particular counter example so so what we
do first is we have to choose a strategy
which means that the min player has to
choose which option to choose and as you
can see we're only interested in one two
three of these nodes because here we
have two options we can give either go
down or we can go to the right so let's
say that we start with this particular
initial strategy and then what we can do
is we can compute the value right now so
this one is one right because it's the
average of one and one this one is one
as well and of course that one is one as
well we can also compute the values of
DS over here so this one is 1/2 and this
one is 7/8 now you can see that this one
is locally not optimal right because if
I switch it will become smaller right
and we're trying to minimize this so
what we'll do is we'll switch this one
over here and as you can see the value
becomes smaller so that's good so that's
our first step
and now we can can see actually that we
could we could switch this one as well
because it becomes smaller as well but
now we can can switch to the first one
back again because it will become
smaller as well and I hope you see that
there's this counter going on so then we
switch this one then we can switch this
one again
so I think we had now all eight I mean
cases of responses one two three
all right so we also did we implemented
the three algorithms as well and did
some comparison of the of the
performance gives a simple example of a
particular algorithm and models it as a
labeled Markov chain and then ran the
three algorithms so if you do the one
with the first order first theory over
the reals I mean it really goes nowhere
I mean it's it's just simply too big I
mean the formula becomes huge and if you
run the algorithm it's not going
anywhere so for the second one the best
I can tell you that it takes more than
ten hours because my grad students send
me an email this morning I mean there
are three hours ahead this is it it's
still running it's still running so I
can't tell you exactly the amount but at
least ten hours
now the third algorithm which as we've
seen in the worst case is exponential is
extremely efficient and you can see ten
hours versus a couple of seconds also
what you can do is you can actually pre
process and first more less compute
which states are probabilistic by
similar and then run the algorithm and
it turns out that actually this gives a
speed-up so what we've seen is that the
algorithm that was introduced by bachi
at all is is really simple policy
iteration and one of the key key things
that we observed is that you need to
decide probablistic by similarity before
you actually compute two distances and
this is not actually the only example
where we've seen that although we're
interested in in a much more refined and
continuous notion of equivalence first
deciding this more discrete notion
really helps I mean for example for the
ellipsoid algorithm you can you can
prove that if you first decide
probablistic by similarity then the
problem becomes fully dimensional and
then you get a more efficient ellipsoid
algorithm as well we still not very
efficient but it does help
robots because you to do this first is
it continuous to the UN perfect notion
of exact by summation what do you mean
exactly alright maybe I asked her
getting at the end of the talk
shown a simple example that it actually
takes an exponential time but it in
practice it works really really well so
we've been doing some some related work
so we're also interested in in this
notion of of general policy iteration so
the key difference between simple and
general policy iteration is that in
simple policy iteration in in the loop
you update a single vertex in every
iteration that is locally non optimal
and then you recompute everything
whereas in general policy iteration you
try to you more you switch all the
vertices that are locally non optimal
and then you recompute oh it seems that
this might actually be more efficient
and furthermore what we've done is we
we've applied at least where we've done
already simple policy iteration for for
for models that they can also express
not only probabilistic by notions but
also non-deterministic notions so
probablistic automata we've done it for
simple policy iteration turns out that
in that particular case you not only
have to decide first the states that
have distant 0 that is our probe list ik
by similar but you also have to decide
the states that have distance 1 that are
most for the most part but that can be
done in polynomial time we're still
looking to see if we can extend this to
the to the general policy iteration
setting as well
I so and here's a number of states
alright and we're talking to the
complexity of you said it was let n be
the number of states sure since the I
mentioned many applications n is
exponential and already and some natural
parameters right and then probably so
even doing a single pass a pilot policy
iterations to expenses so is there is
there work that looks at say
approximately computing the distance up
to some error with high probability and
say doesn't necessarily even best to get
all all the possible states people have
been using sampling in order to do this
and so and then so from your perspective
are those is there some reason are you
working in some setting where guarantees
provided by the sampling algorithms just
not cut it for some application or maybe
in practice like are these for these
methods competitive with ones that are
doing say much more
they're definitely not comparatively the
sampling
the guarantee said they provide
we exactly computed distances for as
otherwise
but very similar I mean you know not
exactly the same question with something
similar so so all this is predicated on
the promise of having a robust some
something some notion of equivalence or
Nia knots which is robust in the setting
and it can be that we don't know the
probabilities very well or it can be
that maybe we have a reduced coarse
grained version of the system which is
too large to to run that type of
algorithm on so for the first question
do you actually prove that you're by
summation metric is continuous with
respect to some kind of topology on the
you know that's in the finite case in
this set of weights of your yes so so
the idea is that for example you know if
you take a system and you modify so that
the the one of the probabilities
continuously you know well will your
your distance function be continuous as
well that's the case it's down or
something
do we know can I mean so there are so
many sheets bounds for example in when
you want to compose systems
so he is operated from from from process
algebra you take these systems and you
can combine them then you again the idea
of in the boolean setting what you would
like is that the behavioral equivalence
is a congruence right and in in this
particular setting what you would like
is that the operators are non expensive
with respect to the distance function
brenn zero would be funny right if you
try to turn something from zero
probability on and then I realized to my
question about what if it's what if you
go from zero probability to some really
average day to positive probability and
now something that was impossible is not
possible in the long run that would seem
to sense that would seem to maybe would
still be continuous but I would I would
be surprised if you could put some kind
of Lipschitz ban others still in the
same vein how does it be able to respect
to averaging probably stick systems do
you know we have this theory of you're
given an ambient probability do we know
something about our the by seniority
metric behave under this kind of
transformation you know I would now
other notion of approximants maybe I
should say has some some
season four probabilistic automata only
light but there is no knowledge that
their minis matter order or in the
desert park or they algorithm Ebonics or
400 when you have an undetermined
easement okay so in the case that we we
moved to probabilistic automata the
mapping becomes different because you
have both min and Max knows particular
setting so the algorithm becomes
different in a sense as well
now the complexity is harder so for for
labeled Markov chains we can compute the
polynomial time and for probabilistic
automata we shown that it's in in ppad
but
one more I can actually say something
about your quote your question so this
metric in particular the ones that Frank
presented goes well with the statistic
model checking so if you can in a
statistical statistical checking your
answer a question probabilistic original
given confidence then we can use this
this distance to then infer within
another give before lower confidence the
same property proper probability for
another close enough
right thank you for breaking out the
bunch and I believe